i think it's a pretty common story i was
going through like drinking and drugs
and random gig jobs and hanging out with
actors and going to acting class and
like you said having no idea who i was
and um like covering up
my deep well of uncertainty with alcohol
and cigarettes
did you smoke a lot and drink a lot
oh my god the most in drugs and drinking
and smoking
what kind of drugs i mean you just you
snorted you powdered your nose
yeah um let's see i've done oh god am i
i can't get arrested for things i didn't
know people no i talked i've done
cocaine i've done
yeah
i've done everything
except for heroin good
and heroin adjacent things but i've done
like oh i haven't done acid but i've
done mushrooms i don't trust the acid i
won't do it i won't do acid i don't
trust it
my brain doesn't like it yeah i'll melt
um i've done pills i've done yeah i mean
i've done what you've done yeah we like
like but i i somehow
the only one that's that's stuck was
alcohol
stuck is then you still do it no it's
and i had to literally quit it like i
had to get sober the rest of them i kind
of could take or leave and i dabbled in
coke and then left coke and some people
dabble in coke and they can't [ __ ]
let go yeah
but for me i
alcohol just pickled my brain and i had
disney i had to leave the party was it
something that you were like wow i need
a drink i need a drink in the morning i
need a drink in the afternoon i want to
have four glasses of wine it just felt
like it was consuming you yeah it was a
[ __ ] alcoholic i am an alcoholic
wow and so you went through the 12-step
program and all that stuff i'm in the
middle of steps right now and let me
tell you that's not fun
but um yeah i have a meeting and a
sponsor and all that talk about coming
clean and being honest with yourself and
just like that's got to be [ __ ] hard
though like to really tell the truth
like we could sit here and tell people
all day
the things that we think they want to
hear or or sugarcoat it but when you get
into these kind of positions where
you're
in a 12 step it you're just hurting
yourself if you're not honest
yes you're just [ __ ] yourself
essentially
yeah
um my favorite thing about getting sober
is that i stopped lying
and i wasn't like a big liar like i
wasn't
but like my whole life i had told tiny
lives
like oh i owned a horse when i was a kid
i [ __ ] did not own a horse when i was
a kid
things like that things that like
completely arbitrary lies for no reason
whatsoever just a [ __ ] liar
and i would constantly get caught in
them because i forget that i lied about
it so so much of my
mental
energy was like who did i lie to about
what and if i tell the story
and now i just don't do it anymore and
like it leads to some awkward moments in
the moment but i never have to keep my
story straight right